[Music]
[Music]
so what are you doing out here there is
a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of
a tree that heals or it could change the
world but if it gets into the wrong
hands he could awaken a great evil
I believe that the legend is real which
was man I'm gonna find it you are when I
do
just imagine the lives that could be
saved I've been looking for this tree
longer than anybody I've tracked the
legend to every village every island be
searching for something it can't be
found but you've never had the key let's
do something that's safe let's go see
some elephants they're all no elephants
in the Amazon and I don't even like
elephants lady everybody likes elephants
know this about the jungle
everything that you see wants to kill
you and can
careful make it smell fear
oh my god
who brings a submarine to the Amazon
FOIA
goodnight
[Music]
don't get it come on I got it I don't
got it that was a disaster
go away
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it
hello I just wanted you to know this has
been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up I'm a
Duke
look out
rotters
latest ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world we're headed upriver lagrimas
de cristo for mr. schirra
travel come on not a good time my
brother looking for passage upriver
please go away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends do you believe in curses -
you gonna beg minutes are back well I
look forward to disappointing you ten
thousand to bring you there alive dead
its 15,000 where should I pay me dead
dead I'd have to carry you beds a lot
harder lady here we go
oh oh sorry Frank it's alright strong
for me
I can swim you put the river cruise and
you can't swim
the price just went up
[Music]